but i'd hurt you like condiment of shoe
leather
but i tell you what i think you made a
great metaphor
for about what's going on here
look at your family really proud and uh
and joanne i want to thank you for all
you do to lift up this community
bringing pride and dignity uh and jobs
in milwaukee
my dad used to have an expression he's
he lost his job in scranton pennsylvania
when i was a kid
and we uh he took us to my grandpop's my
mom's
dad my grandmom was passed
and so we said you're gonna live here
for about a year i'm gonna commute every
day from
scranton pennsylvania down to wilmington
delaware where there's jobs joey and
when we get it when i get one
i'll be back for you and you mom and
your brother and uh
sister my sister's with me today too
where's my sister valerie
she's my best friend in the world anyway
val
and uh and he said it's only 157 miles
away
wilmington delaware you come home every
weekend
and when he got when we got down to
wilmington and he finally got a job
that we could bring us down and be able
to rent an apartment
he used to always have an expression
sheriff he'd say you know joey your
job's about
a lot more than a paycheck it's about
your dignity
it's about respect it's about your place
in the community
it's about being able to look your kid
in the eye and say honey it's gonna be
okay
it's gonna be okay as gwen knows there's
not an awful lot of people
out there right now a lot of
hard-working people who can't say it's
going to be okay
they're in trouble statistics show for
example that
over 50 of the american people think
actually it's 49
to be precise
and anticipate they'd have to borrow the
money or sell something
so a lot of people are still hurting and
gwen
let's send her back because i tell you
what she is a voice from milwaukee a
voice for the country
and i'm sure glad you're on my side kid
i'm sure glad you're on my side because
i'm on yours
i want to thank you all for welcoming
your name tom you've been a good friend
for a long time thank you
tom tom endorsed me when uh they said
joe who's running for what anyway but
thank you tom
and sheriff
sheriff lucas and sheriff mahoney
and ambassador joe prince i want to
thank you all for being here there you
are
okay look it's great to be back with you
folks there's only four days left
millions of americans have already voted
they tell me now it's up to about 85
million americans have already voted
and millions more are going to vote
before this election is over
and i believe when you use your power
the power to vote
you can change the course of the country
and quite frankly right now the course
of the world because it's leaderless now
we're going to start right here in
wisconsin
tom remembers i came up here campaigning
for hillary
and uh for a whole lot of reasons not
all which were her fault
he ended up not taking it as seriously
we thought it was different i've been
here a lot
and by the way when i get elected if i
get elected
i'm coming back tom
look in these final days you got to we
got to keep our sense of empowerment
here
a sense of optimism what we can do
together
but i know it's hard more than 225
000 people i think it's 229 as i speak
have already lost their lives to cover
19.
2 000 here in wisconsin 600 here in
milwaukee county
each one memorialized by an empty chair
this morning at breakfast
or tonight at dinner an empty chair
macarthur square and now folks are
getting hit
by a new big wave of infections across
the country
this week wisconsin like other states
set a new record for daily cases
hospitals are running short on beds
just had to open a field hospital that's
what we're facing
we've now hit nine million cases
in the united states of america we make
up
four percent of the world's population
we have 20 percent of the world's deaths
9 million new cases nationwide
another tragic milestone millions of
people out of work
on the edge and they can't see the light
they're not sure how dark it's going to
remain
wisconsin is down twenty thousand
manufacturing jobs
the evening since his pandemic began
and the thing that bothers me the most
was a president who
gave up over the weekend his chief of
staff said what we knew
quote we're not going to control the
pandemic end of code
we're not going to control the pandemic
that last week when i debated the
president
he said quote we're rounding the corner
it's going away
we're learning to live with it you may
remember what i said it may have been
viewed as harsh by some
i told them we're not learning to live
with it you're asking us to learn and to
die with it
because people continue to die it's
estimated that over 200
000 more people will die between now and
the end of the year
by the leading experts who haven't been
wrong yet
you know did you hear what he said today
he said today at a rally that our
doctors
are the problem because they're putting
their lives on the line
busting their next he said they're
making up deaths from cover 19
because they get more money
they're making up deaths people aren't
really dying from cover they're dying
for other things
but they're saying it's covered to make
the numbers go up
my lord by the way is monica why we're
here
monica is an icu nurse
i spent some time with monica on the
phone and and her two kids
and monica told me what my son-in-law
was a doc in philly told me
and this all began while we were waiting
for
ppp the mask and the gowns and all the
gear
so many ducks so many nurses
so many first responders after they took
did their job were afraid to go home
because they'd take it home the virus
home with their children
monica told me how her husband weighed
in the garage so she could change and
put on a bathroom before she run the
house
and shower so many
people over a thousand monica's
have given their lives trying to savor
their lives
and this guy says that
they're raking it up because they want
to make more money
doctors and nurses go today and go go to
work every single day
donald trump should stop attacking him
and start doing his job
this is the same man who told us when we
were told what he was told
about four weeks ago three four weeks
ago that
we were losing a thousand lives a day
remember what he said
he said it is what it is
isn't that useful it is what it is
well it is what it is because he is who
he is
that's the problem donald trump waved
the white flag
surrendered to the virus but the
american people don't give up
we don't give in unlike donald trump
we're not going to surrender to this
virus we're simply not going to
surrender
look i put in place a plan
with this pandemic responsibly i set it
out back in may
and then again in june and in july
the way we can bring this country
together around testing tracing masking
it's estimated that by leading doctors
in america if we just wore these masks
for the remainder of this calendar year
we could save up to another hundred
thousand lives
dr fauci who's been
not treated very well by the president
who's been with
three other presidents in the same role
one most respected guys in the world
he's called for a masked mandate this
isn't a political statement of us
wearing these masks
for god's sake it's a patriotic duty
the reason you're wearing the mask is
not to save yourself but the
save your neighbor the person across
from you
the person who you're next to but still
donald trump refuses to listen to the
science
he's politicized the race for vaccine as
well instead of planning for its safe
equitable and free distribution
what's he doing he's talking about
things that are just not even the realm
of possibility we'll have this by
september we'll have a bite that goes on
look folks he refused to bring leaders
by the way both parties together
you know the house of representatives
gwen can tell you
has already passed three major pieces of
legislation
who cares act and then the heroes act
provides all the money that is necessary
to safely open schools and businesses
and do it in a way that they can stay
open
but it costs money look at all the
people who've gone out of business all
the small businesses
we know how to open business we know
what to do with safety but it costs
to open our schools nationwide it's
estimated it will cost 200 billion
dollars
to do it safely provide everybody with
the ppe
private everybody change the ventilation
systems make sure you have
you have separators make sure you're in
a position where
we have the sanitary conditions that are
wiped down
smaller classes more teachers
but what do we do the money's already
been there they've already passed it
what's happened president hasn't got out
of his golf bunker and
his golf course in the summer or the
bunker in the white house
since then to bring people together
look find anybody democrat or republican
who served in the congress the senate
the house
ask them can i ever remember a time
when there's been a national crisis and
this is a national crisis
that the president hasn't brought them
all together and said we're staying here
till we fix this
we're going to work it out he hadn't
even
talked to y'all look folks
we're going to bring the republicans and
democrats together and deliver economic
relief for working families and schools
and businesses i promise you
i know how to do this as i said before
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down the virus
look donald donald trump inherited a
strong economy from
barack and me but he squandered that
economy just like he squandered
everything he's inherited
frankly i've dealt with guys like trump
my whole life
guys who think they're better than you
because they have a lot of money
look down on you because they live in a
better home
i'll tell you what we understand
we understand how this works folks
the people who built this country
weren't wall street and investment
bankers
and ceos they're hard-working americans
middle-class folks working-class folks
that built the middle class and unions
built the middle class look
we know we know as gwen said we can
build back better
with an economy that rewards work not
wealth right now it rewards wealth not
work
we can do without raising taxes on any
working person middle class
i give you my word is abide and if you
make less than four
hundred thousand dollars if i'm elected
president
you're not going to see a penny of your
taxes go up not a penny
he keeps lying about my plan
but i tell you what i'm going to ask the
wealthiest americans
and the biggest corporations by the way
91 of the fortune 500 companies
pay no tax at all zero
zero tax they make billions of dollars
folks it's about time people start
paying their fair share
it's not a punishment pay your fair
share
why should a firefighter why should a
sheriff why should a cop why should an
educator why should a nurse
pay a higher tax rate which you do
than they pay you do that
that you pay a higher tax rate and by
the way
why should you pay more taxes than
donald trump
750 bucks
this guy loves talking about corruption
i've released 22 years of my tax returns
you can go online and see him well guess
what
he hadn't released one single year of
his tax returns
what the hell is he hiding what's in
there
you know working families and middle
class people
you need help they need help
particularly first-term home buyers
be able to pay for health care premiums
child care
care if you're asian loved ones just to
get a new hot water heater i don't know
about you
but the kitchen tables i was raised
around
they're sitting there and i can hear my
dad now well we can't get those four new
tires
because you have to ride on those ball
tires a little while longer
until we get by next month when that hot
water heater goes out what are we going
to do
who's going to tell her she can't go
back to the community college because of
the money
they're the conversations taking place
all across america today
and what's trump trying to do raise your
cost
and standard of living he's going to be
in the supreme court
even if we win he'll still be the
supreme court
in nine days for 10 days
asking the supreme court with their new
justice
who was put on the court for the purpose
of destroying the affordable care act
to rip it out rooting branch eliminate
it
all if they get their way
100 million americans will lose
protections for pre-existing conditions
including 2.5 million wisconsinites
2.4 if you have diabetes you've had
cancer if you have breast cancer
whatever it is
whatever your pigs is a condition you
won't be able to afford it
because they can jack up the price
beyond your capacity
women will once again once again
be charged more for the same health care
than a man is charged for just because
they're a woman
people forget that that's what it was
before
we passed the affordable care act
look donald trump thinks health care is
a privilege
i think it's a right people should have
we all get out of the vote
we'll not only restore obamacare but
we'll strengthen and build on it
so you can keep your private insurance
or you can choose a medicare-like
option that will add to obamacare
which we tried which we wanted to do the
first time it could get the votes
we'll increase subsidies to lower your
premiums and deductibles
out-of-pocket spending and surprise
billings
and we will reduce the cost of
prescriptions by 60 percent
i'm not making that up that comes from
saying we're going to insist
and we have the votes to do it in this
next election
that medicare can negotiate with the
drug
companies to say how much they're going
to willing to pay for whatever drug they
have
look folks we're going to make sure we
keep the protections for people with
pre-existing conditions meanwhile
social security actuary social security
has said
if donald trump gets reelected he says
he's going to change social security
based on the change he wants to make the
actuary at social security said
social security will be bankrupt by
2023.
i'm not making this stuff up it's real
folks i'm going to protect social
security medicare and medicaid
and guess what he's not going to be able
to do it because we're going to win this
election look
let's not forget how weak donald trump
has been
in chaotic he talks about trade policy
my god what a disaster he's been trump's
trade policy has
decimated devastated the wisconsin dairy
industry
in 2017 to 2019 wisconsin lost 15
percent of its dairy farms
and last year wisconsin lost
more dairy farms than any state in the
nation
since the start of the trade war
wisconsin is seeing mass layoffs surged
by 25 the name before
covet hit wisconsin saw big declines in
manufacturing jobs
after trump rolled out his irresponsible
tax giveaways
harley davidson slashed manufacturing
jobs
repurchased almost 700 million dollars
of his own stock
so the corporate heads could get to make
a lot more money
and none of it went to the employees and
then shifted
some of its production overseas so much
for helping look my policies
right now by the way the deficit with
china is higher
than it was in our administration look
at the end of the trump tax loopholes
that incentivized companies to ship jobs
overseas
these new these new laws you just got
passed for real
that's 10 percent i'm going to add a 10
cert
to any company that ships jobs overseas
and companies that invest in
strengthening american manufacturing
or bring jobs back home and offer 10
tax credit and by the way the president
united states
awards over 600 billion dollars in
contracts a year for our
military for all the things we build
federal buildings
well it's not a violation of any trade
law no one's done it but i promise you
i'm going to do it
not a single not a single solitary
contract
we awarded unless all the products used
by that contractor
are made in america all of them
right here in america and by the way
when i talk about my economic plan it's
not some liberal think tank
talks about how good it is moody's
wall street major firms pointed out
after looking at my
plan for economy and his that we will
create
18.6 million jobs under the biden plan
a trillion dollars more in gdp
than trump folks look
the fact is that we're now in a
situation where
this president is in a position that he
doesn't know
what he's doing if you notice if you
notice what donald trump has spent a lot
of time doing
he spent a lot of time rolling out
irresponsible
corporate tax cuts in the meantime do
you realize
that during this pandemic
the billionaires in america billionaires
they're all listed
have made over 300 billion dollars more
300 billion dollars more how about you
guys
you all doing great right you got all
that money look folks
we're in a situation where the president
now
finds himself the thing that bothers me
most about all he's done
is the way he talks about our military
being
suckers and losers think about this
a lot of you women and men served in the
military a lot of wisconsinites sir
my son beau gave up the attorney
general's job
in the state of delaware to volunteer to
go to iraq for a year
he won the bronze star the conspicuous
service medal
he came home with cancer after being
near burma he came home anyway he was
given months to live
and guess what he wasn't a loser he
wasn't a sucker he was a patriot
just like your sons and daughters
your parents and grandparents look folks
if you ever wonder you know trump keeps
talking about how strong he is
he's strong and the other rest of the
nations listen to him
everybody's afraid of him let me tell
you what
he's the first president i'm aware of in
american history
that six generals including his former
chief of staff six of them
left resigned and said
he wasn't fit to be commander-in-chief
general stanley mcchrystal special
operations commander
command he's the guy who oversaw the bin
laden
bill mcgraven and 22 he saw the over he
oversaw
he he was a seal he headed up the seals
and 22
four stars have endorsed me
saying they trust me to be the next
commander-in-chief for the united states
military
folks it's about respect
it's about support and that's why
the military times which your staff
tried to wipe out
military time just wrote an article
saying war
active duty troops support biden
than trump so much for the guy
who talks about what a tough guy is and
why everybody listens to him
look that's why we have to support the
military
and we have to make sure we should
considerably invest
more which i can't don't take the time
to talk to you tonight about
but invest significantly more in dealing
with the veterans administration and
while donald trump
fails to condemn white supremacy we can
vote to deliver racial justice
folks a season of protest has broken out
all over this nation
and protesting is not burning and
looting
and violence never must never be
tolerated it won't that's not protesting
but those protests are cries for justice
the names of george floyd brianna taylor
jacob blake
they're not going to soon be forgotten
not by me not by us not by this country
we have to vote to meet the challenge of
climate crisis as well
more frequent extreme weather but
literally the planet's at stake
we're told the number of years before
it's irreversible is
getting narrower and narrower the west
is on fire
more forest land has been burned to the
ground
than the entire square miles
of rhode island and connecticut combined
the midwest is flooding here in
wisconsin extreme weather
incurs big costs for your infrastructure
lake michigan set a record high this
past january
and the south and the east hurricanes
are more severe oceans are rising
my state's only three feet above sea
level literally
people are worried what happens if we
don't change this
folks donald trump thinks
that when you say climate change he says
hoax
well this stable genius as he calls
himself
also thinks that wind power causes
cancer
the way to stop hurricanes coming across
the warm atlantic from africa
is to maybe drop a nuclear bomb on them
the same stable genius said the problem
we had in the revolutionary war
we didn't have up we did enough airports
in the revolutionary war god
saved the uh anyway look
when i hear climate change i think the
health of our children
the security of the planet and i also
think it creates
jobs jobs here in wisconsin all across
the country
folks combating climate change means
saving the planet protecting our health
and creating millions of good-paying
jobs union jobs
right here in milwaukee and all across
america we can change the path we're on
but we have to act now because we can't
afford four more years of donald trump
this election i promise you
is going to hit your grandkids are going
to write about
how it set the path for at least a
generation
here in america you know in 2008 and
2012 we came to you all barack and me
and we asked for your help you helped us
and each day we are in office we work
for you
and the entire country i'm going to do
that again
my 2020 campaign is a broad coalition
we welcome democrats and republicans and
independents
i'm running as a proud democrat but i'm
going to govern as an american president
there will be no blue states or red
states just the united states
i'll work as hard for those who vote
against me as those who voted for me
because that's what a president is
supposed to do
the duty to care the duty to care for
everyone
look you too have a sacred duty
to vote it matters wisconsin matters
so if you haven't already and most of
you probably have make a plan vote
get out the vote if you've already voted
get your mom dad brother sister neighbor
get them to vote go to iwillvote.com
you've got to get it done to make sure
everyone knows
where to vote when to vote look
a press article yesterday speaking of
donald trump
two days ago actually said and i quote
never before in modern presidential
politics
has a candidate been so reliant on
wide-scale efforts to depress the vote
as donald trump
so let's be careful here guess what
he's not going to be able to stop us not
at all
as i said he'll not silence the over 85
million people have already
voted they've had enough
people are coming out in droves waiting
three four five
six hours in other states just to vote
let me conclude by saying i'll never
forget
the phrase used by president kennedy
when he decided to send us to the moon
get to the moon
he said when asked why i said he
refused to postpone we're the united
states of america
we refuse to postpone the incredible
opportunities available in the american
people
i refuse to postpone the enormous
possibilities we have
i've been around a while but i've never
been more optimistic about america's
chances than i am today i really mean it
there's nothing beyond our capacity
nothing
there's no limit to what america can do
we're the only country in the history of
the world that's come out of every
crisis
stronger than when we went in the only
thing that can tear
america apart is america itself
and that's exactly what donald trump has
been doing from the beginning
of his campaign last time out dividing
america
pitting americans against one another
based on race
gender religion national origin
ethnicity
it's wrong that's not who we are
everybody knows who donald trump is
let's let us know who we are who we are
in the last four days we choose hope
over fear
unity over division science over fiction
and yes truth over lies
so folks it's time to stand up
and take back our democracy we can do
this
we can better we'll be better than we've
been
we can be who we want to be at our best
the united states of america i promise
you
we can do this you help me get there
i promise you i'll take responsibility
when i make a mistake i'll acknowledge
it
but i will take responsibility and i
won't let you down
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you for your patience thank you
thank you thank you
all thanks right
i appreciate it
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
oh
[Music]